اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في نافذه التحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
نستضيف المحلل العسكري والخبير
الاستراتيجي الواء فايز الدويري ونتابع
بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على
الخارطه التفاعليه مع سلام خضر سلام شكرا
زين سنبدا من شمال قطاع غزه
لاسباب
اي يعني بالغت الاهميه لان كتائب القسام
نشرت
فيديو مصور يظهر او جانب من الاشتباكات
بينه وبين قوات الاحتلال في حيي الدرج
والتفاح شمال قطاع غزه كان قد قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ اكثر من اسبوع انه قلص الى
حد بعيد القدرات القتاليه لحركه حماس
وقدرات اطلاق الصواريخ اليوم راينا فيديو
يظهر كثافه النار التي تطلقها كتائب
القسام على اليات اسرائ يه متوغل في بعض
مناطق حيي الدرج والتفاح
استهدافات
بالاسلحه ال المحموله على الكتف بالقذائف
المحموله على الكتف اصابات مباشره عند
الاليات وايضا اصابات لتجمعات جنود
اسرائيليين وبحسب ما يبدو هناك خسائر وقعت
في صفوف هؤلاء ليس فقط جراح ولكن من
الواضح ان منهم من قتل الشمال ايضا اليوم
شهد اشتباكات في بعض مناطق جباليا وجباليا
البلد وجباليا المخيم اشتباكات كانت عنيفه
وكانت مكثفه بالتزامن مع معلومات ميدانيه
تقول بان الاليات الاسرائيليه عادت منذ
ثلاثه ايام تقريبا لتنتشر عند ال الشاطئ
يعني بالمنطقه القريبه جدا من السواحل
سواحل الشمال اي شمال قطاع غزه بالانتقال
الى الوسط اليوم وسط القطاع كان مركزا
لاشتباكات عنيفه وضاره على اكثر من محور
ولكن الاساسي في هذه
ال التطورات الميدانيه اليوم كانت الهجوم
على الزوايده وهي جبهه جديده فتحت في هذه
المنطقه اسرائيل كانت تحاول التوغل في
مخيمات الوسط الصيرات البريج والمغازي من
ثلاثه محاور من الشرق ومن الغرب ومن
الشمال كان هناك صعوبه بالغه لتوغل
الاليات في البريج على سبيل المثال
وبالتحديد في البريج نتيجه الكثافه
الناريه لكتائب القسام قامت اسرائيل
بتوسيع هذه الدائره والهجوم
عبر مخيم الزوايده او بلده الزوايده في
محاوله منها لاختراق خط الوسط والوصول الى
داخل البريج وبطبيعه الحال قسمت المنطقه
عزلت هذه المنطقه بالكامل تقريبا عن دير
البلح حيث توجد المستشفى الاساسي نذكر
بهذا لانها مساله اساسيه وبالتالي لا يعود
المصابون والجرحى قادرون على الانتقال الى
دير البلح علما ان قناصه تنتشر على طول
شارع صلاح الدين وهناك استهدافات لاي شخص
يحاول ال انتقال عبر هذا
الشارع وبموازاة
ولكن اليوم كان هناك عمليات كبيره في
خزاعه وفي بني سهيلا وفي الجراره ايضا
هناك عمليات واشتباكات من مسافات قريبه
جدا اضافه الى بقاء خان يوز نس منطقه
اشتباك قويه ووسط تفجيرات تقوم بها القوات
قوات الاحتلال في بعض المناطق في خان يونس
وعادت ايضا في خزاعه لتفجر مناطق واسعه
هذه المنطقه تصفها
قوات الاحتلال بانها المركز الاساسي
للانفاق الاستراتيجيه والتكتيكيه اي انفاق
القياده وانفاق الهجوم
لحركه لكتائب القسام ونختم بسؤال ورد
اليوم في مقال عند الواشنطن بوست تساءل
الواشنطن بوست في ما سمتها حرب الانفاق
الاولى في القرن ال 21 قارنت بين الانفاق
التي وصفتها بانها متطوره لكتائب القسام
وبين الانفاق التي تواجدت خلال حرب فيتنام
وقارنت بين الصعوبات تقول الصحيفه بانه من
الصعب جدا على جيش النظامي ان يهزم
الانفاق ومن يقاتل عبر وفي الانفاق بهذا
نعود اليك زين ربما قراءه اوسع في مجريات
الامور الميدانيه هذا هو السؤال الكبير في
الواقع السلام منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وحتى
قبل بدايه
وهنا نتذكر ما يشار اليه دائما قول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في زياراته الاولى
لاسرائيل انه بحث بدائل الحرب البريه
اللواء فايز الدويري اطلعت معنا على
الخريطه التفاعليه مع السلام اشتباكات في
مختلف المحاور في القطاع لكن
اي يعني هل هنالك اي شيء مختلف في اليوم
ال3 لهذه الحرب نعم يعني اذا ذهبنا للقاطع
الشمالي مدينه غزه
ومحيطها لم يعد هناك تواجد حقيقي لقوات
جيش الاحتلال في الاحياء الشرقيه على
الاقل يعني منذ عده ايام نتحدث انه بدا
ينكفئ وبدا يتراجع
وبقي فقط في منطقه جبل الريس واليوم كمان
بدا ينسحب من منطقه جبل الريس ومعظم
انسحابات تذهب الى خارج قطاع غزه الى
الغلاف بمعنى اخر كان المنطقه الش كمرحله
ثانيه اوشكت على الانتهاء وبالتالي ستبقى
عمليات التي تحدثوا عنها بانها العمليات
التي ترتبط بالمرحله الثالثه استخدام
القصف من اجل عمليات الاغتيال او تنفيذ
عمليات بريه محدوده في ضد هدف طارئ يظهر
لهم فكان القاطع الشمالي انته انتهت او
اوشكت على الانتهاء اذا ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الوسطى المنطقه الوسطى هي تقريب قريبا
الان الاسخن ام في معارك القطاع الان
كما تحدثت سلام
هو الاطار العام للمعركه الان البريج
يهاجم من ثلاثه اتجاهات بصوره عامه من
الشمال والشرق ومن الغرب ويحاول ان يدخل
هو في البدايه كان الهجوم من الجنوب
وتراجع وتوقف فدفع بالاتجاهات
الشرقيه والشمال
والغربيه لانه بعد ان دخل المنطقه مع
شوارع صلاح الدين فصل سيرات والزوايده عن
البريج والمغازي ويحاول فصل الزوايده عن
دير البلح انسرات يهاجم من اتجاهين من من
الشرق ومن الشمال ومن الشمال الغربي اتجاه
لانه الشمال والشمال الغربي عمليه واحده
الزوايده بدا يهاجم بها من الغرب ويحاول
ان يجري عمليات انزال لكن وكذلك المغازي
من الج الجنوب يهاجمه لكن يبدو لي انه
الان يسعى بعد هذه التجزئه الرئيسيه لل
وتقسيم ان يحاول ان يقسمها الى اربعه
مناطق سيحاول الدخول في عمق هذه المناطق
لكن يواجه مقاومه ضاريه جدا وظهرت له
اي اشاره جديده بان المغرا التي تعتبر ارض
زراعيه انها ستكون شقيقه جحر الديك
فبالتالي عاد ليتعامل مع منطقه المغرقه
اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب
خان يونس الى منطقه خان يونس كذلك الموقف
معقد بصوره كبيره جدا رغم انه
دخل الى من كوسو فيم وسار ووصل الى مدينه
حمد
والمواصفات في الاطراف الخارجيه اذا ذهبنا
الى
شرق خان يونس منطقه بنيس زنا عبسان عبسان
الكبيره خزاعه الفخاري خزاعه لها قصه
مختلفه بعد ان تقدمت القوات بدات خزاعه
تقض مضاجعه فعاد وارسل لواء من النسق
الثاني للتعامل مع منطقه خزاعه والتي هي
قريبه جدا من السياج عبسان الكبيره بني
سيله عبسان الجديده هو دخل في الاجزاء
الشماليه من عبسان الجديده وفي الاجزاء
الجنوبيه من عبسان الكبيره لكنه لم يستطع
ان يحقق اي تقدم ل كان عملياته تتصف
بالحذر الزائد لماذا لانه هي المنطقه اذا
نظرنا الى الخارطه هذا اذا كان على سبيل
المثال كرقم تقريبي الكيلومتر المربع
الواحد داخل مدينه غزه يوجد به لنفرض
مجازا 20 فتحه نفق هون الكيلومتر المربع
الواحد قد يكون في 200 فتحه نفق وبالتالي
احتماليه خروج المقاتلين تبدو وارده من اي
نقطه لانه المسافات البينيه هذه تسا تساعد
في فيما يتعلق ب خان يونس كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال بالامس انه لو اسناك تاتي
الى
الموقع بالامس قال انه السيطره على القاطع
الشمالي لخان يونس يتطلب شهرا السيطره على
القاطع الجنوبي لخان يونس يتطلب اشهرا ولم
يتحدث عن المنطقه الشرقيه اه نعم ولم
يتحدث عن المنطقه الشرقيه ا اليوم هرس
ليفي يقول انه خرج من خان يونس من اي من
اي مكان من خان يونس الان هو دخل الى نفق
اين هذا النفق لا يكن لم يكن هناك اي
دلاله او مؤشر اذا كان شمال خانيونس يحتاج
الى شهر وجنوب خان يونس يحتاج الى اشهر
شرق خان يونس يحتاج الى سنوات ام اذا
اخذنا بهذا المقياس لكن هل هذا الاطار
الزمني متاح هل يستطيع ان يخوض هذه
المعركه في ظل الانقسام الداخل الحاد داخل
مجلس الحرب وانقسام الشارع هل هو
يستطيع ان يفرض هذا التصور على الدول
الداعمه لو يتوقف لو لو يلوح بالعصا
الغليظه من قبل الرئيس بايدن بانه سيوقف
تصدير ارسال الذخائر وليس السلاح اعتقد
نتنياهو س يقلب ظهر المجن لكل متابعيه
ويحاول ان يرضخ اذا دعني اقول لا يوجد شيء
واضح لكن الواضح ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لن
يستطيع ان يخوض حرب مفتوحه اكثر من
اسبوعين اه هذا هو الفيديو الذي كنا نعلق
عليه في النشره السابقه والان نريد ان
نعلق عليه تعليقات سريعه
اي هذا فيديو للاشتباكات في حيي التفاح
والدرج والدرج نعم هذه اللي هو يعني نهايه
نهايه المعركه نهايه المعركه تم تصوير هذه
اللقطات تم تدمير ثلاث دبابات واربع
دبابات وجارف وال الجارفه لم تدمر تم قتل
عناصرها لكن الغريب في انها كانت اولا من
مسافات قريبه جدا يعني سنشاهد في في هذه ه
هذه
تصوير رائع هناك اليه هندسيه في الامام
والدبابه في الخلف واستهدف استهدف الدبابه
التي تقع خلف الاليه او المعده الهندسيه
لكن لاحظ لاحظ هذه اللقطه ا من اين خرج من
المنزل كم يبعد 15 20 متر لانه قطع الاثار
التفجير وصلته النار جاءت اليه يعني هو في
قلب النار نعم الغبار والنار والدخان
هذا هو هذا هي هي هذه هي طريقه قتال رجال
القسام
وقه هل هل لم يكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يعمل
حساب لهذه الطريقه هو يعني طريقه اداره
المعركه الدفاعيه لا الجيش الاسرائيلي ولا
غير الجيش الاسرائيلي ولا احنا كنا نتوقع
ان اداره المعركه الدفاعيه ستكون بهذه
النجاعه و بهذ اقول و يعني اعيد امر احنا
خدمنا في الجيوش و دخلنا دورات في دول
مختلفه واطلعنا على عقاد قتاليه مختلفه
مهما اختلفت العقاد القتاليه هناك قواسم
مشتركه بين العقيده البريطانيه والامريكيه
حتى الروسيه يعني في قواسم مشتركه لانه
نفكر من داخل وعاء معين هؤلاء يفكرون من
خارج الصندوق خارج هذا الوعاء هذا الصندوق
تمام شكرا شكرا جزيلا الواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه وشكرا
لزميله سلام